Kamala Harris gave a rousing oratory
just the other day in which she
explained how rocket ships work
which brings me to May 30th 2020.
Bob and Doug returned to the Kennedy
Space Center
they suited up
they waved to their families
and they rode an elevator up nearly 20
stories
they strapped in to their seats and
waited as the tanks beneath them filled
with tens of thousands of gallons of
fuel
and then
it launched
yeah they did
they did
they did that
that's what a rocket ship is Kamala
Harris
sounds to me like the student in your
class who thought that essays and term
papers and even question and answer
sessions
were were just about filling the space
with words
that's that's all that it was about this
is this woman has less to say than any
person I have ever seen in public life
she talks just as much as anybody in
public life but she has nothing to say
what is it what is one thing that Kamala
Harris has ever said that has carried
with it any meaning
there's one answer to this as far as I'm
concerned and it's during the Democrat
primaries in 2020 she called Joe Biden a
racist
that's the one thing she ever said that
was
seemed concrete seemed like it had a
purpose seemed specific and then by the
way she walked it back and she said no I
don't think he's racist but he's a he he
supported segregation he was going to
keep me off a school bus or something
and
that was other otherwise it's just wow
microscopes allow you to see small
things and rocket ships go boom
wow and it goes up and then wow huh
don't it's very it would be very sad
I was going to say that she's the the
least impressive politician I've ever
seen it's not true she's very impressive
I am impressed by her vicuity I am
impressed by her vipity and I can't
imagine that life could you imagine
you go into politics you suffer the
slings and arrows all of the attacks
people make on you you forego in in many
cases making better money elsewhere
there I don't know about Kamala Harris
but there are plenty of politicians who
could make way more money in the private
sector than they do in government I'm
not saying she doesn't make a good
salary as a VP or a senator but she
could she could probably make more money
in the private sector you you get to
spend more time with your family when
you're not in government
you go through all of the this the
indignities that go along with holding
office for what for no purpose
whatsoever just to be there just to be
the vice president
there isn't Kamala Harris doesn't want
to do anything in office she has no
agenda whatsoever
she's a completely empty suit
not a whole lot going on I think between
the ears certainly not a whole lot going
on between the shoulders in terms of her
heart in terms of what stirs her in
nothing at all
she like kind of likes Joe Biden she
just wants to be the vice president
probably ultimately to be the president
could you possibly imagine speaking of
artificial and contrived things the FDA
has just given the go ahead
to lab-grown meat now lab-grown meat is
different from
veggie burgers lab-grown meat is
different from the impossible burger or
the I think Burger King was serving
these for a while they're vegetarian but
they look kind of like meat and they
even are kind of Juicy
and that's not what this is this is this
is actual meat
just not mostly not from animals
the agency says that it considers
chicken that is cultivated from cells
that come from stem cells and all sorts
of weird Frankenstein kind of stuff the
FDA considers this safe for humans to
eat after a review of a chicken product
from upside foods which is a company out
of Berkeley
now this won't be hitting the stores
just yet because they still need to sign
off from the U.S department of
Agriculture the USDA and the FDA team up
to decide which foods you're allowed to
eat but the way it works is that the the
meat the fake meat is cultivated from
real animal cells and so the CEO of
upside Foods a woman named Uma valetti
says that they are quote like a starter
dough it means it's not vegetarian means
that sometimes animals are killed and
eggs are used in the process of this but
but many many fewer animals are are
killed to obtain the same amount of meat
and to all of this I say
[Music]
no thanks
I'm good
no but it tastes the same it probably
doesn't but even if it does nah no thank
you but this is a way where you can have
your meat and not kill the animal too
you can have you this is a way where you
can have the best of all worlds yeah no
I'm good thanks though thanks for the
offer
but why why look rationally on paper
it's all upside and there's no downside
yeah I guess I just don't really believe
you I don't trust the FDA I don't trust
these Regulators I don't trust the
scientists I don't trust these fads in
modern hyper scientific
meats and other food products
I just don't trust that
it seems to me that every new brand new
food fad based on some
highly engineered type of food in the
last many decades has been very bad for
us
and it's always been the same story
the story is this new scientifically
engineered food is really really good
for you and it's way better than all the
traditional foods and you should just
replace all those traditional foods with
this new cheap chemical stuff that we're
giving you
and then what happens some years go by
decades go by and you find out all that
new weird scientifically engineered
stuff is terrible my prediction
this isn't even just my prediction but
sweet little Elisa made this prediction
too so that's how you know it's it's a
good one is that this stuff
is going to be the seed oils of 20 years
from now
so my part of the prediction is that
this lab-grown weird meat that's going
to be the seed oils of 20 years from now
what I know for sure and I'm totally
with sweet little Elise on this
Cricket powder which the libs are all
now trying to put in our Foods
and succeeding in some cases it's going
into Foods in Europe and it's already
here in America in some places
that is going to be the seed oils of of
20 and 30 years from now mark my words
and we are going to go right just as
we're as we're seeing right now with
oils and fats and the way that we cook
foods we're we're now ditching the
soybean oil and the canola oil and it's
called rapeseed oil right it's right
there in the name rapeseed we're
ditching all that stuff and saying
actually you know butter is not so bad
for you actually olive oil and kind of
traditional stuff is not so bad for you
it's going to be the same thing here
with the lips who are trying to make us
eat the bugs and the weird Frankenstein
meat grown in the lab but don't worry
because the genius scientists at the FDA
and all the other Regulatory Agencies
they're telling us it's all fine and
when have they ever gotten something
wrong when it when have they ever been
proven wrong on public health or any
other matter I'm now at the point where
if the FDA tells me to do something I am
inclined to do exactly the opposite
[Music]
foreign